okay so into the spider-verse had the
very difficult task of introducing a new
spider-man into the mainstream for
decades and decades and decades peter
parker has been the person that we
associate with the role and thus
bringing in miles morales to lead us a
movie was a big risk on sony's part add
to this the film was also going to be
animated and there was a big chance that
this wouldn't catch the interest of
general audiences and that miles would
be dead on arrival however spider-man
into the spider-verse is not only one of
the best comic book films of all time
it's also one of the best animated
movies ever made throughout this video
we're going to be going through why we
love it and i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts so if you agree then hit
the thumbs up button and also subscribe
for videos like this every day without
the way welcome to the heavy spoiler
show i'm your friendly neighbourhood
spoiler man now let's get into the video
now we need the spider-verse is somewhat
of a phenomenon in many ways after its
release the film received several
prestigious awards including best
animated feature at the oscars baftas
and the golden globes it features its
own innovative animation style and it
has a whole host of characters that pull
from spider-man's rich history i'd say
that the film is universally liked and
in it there's wonky scene that's
absolutely perfect that is what's up
danger
like what's up danger
[Music]
like what's up danger
now throughout the movie miles very much
deals with the fact that he feels
inadequate compared to the rest of the
spider-man and women that appear in the
film this is shown through the first
costume he buys not fitting and in a
symbolic moment when he enters the
spider cave upon coming across the suit
he stares at one but his face doesn't
quite line up with the mask on display
the same suit was worn by the peter
parker that miles met earlier in the
movie and it somewhat shows that he
doesn't believe he can live up to the
responsibility that spider-man has
throughout the film he's constantly
falling short of where he needs to be
and this even leads to the death of his
uncle aaron aaron is very much the uncle
ben figure in his life and this is
hindered out in the movie with the scene
somewhat mirroring the way that ben died
in the original spider-man film both
figures pass away holding their
opposites hands and aaron bestows in
miles the idea that he's the best of
them and that he can keep going
you're the best of all of us
you're on your way
just
[Music]
just keep going
this very much juxtaposes what aaron
represented in the film and he was
somewhat of a bad influence on him
throughout early on we see that miles
gets in a visions academy but it's clear
that he doesn't want to be there his dad
has to almost give him a police escort
to the door and he purposely flunks
tests in order to avoid living up to
what's expected of him miles will do
whatever he can to get away from this
lifestyle and he's given a paper based
on the book great expectations that's
very much synonymous with his journey in
the movie
rather than doing it though he goes to
his uncle aaron's and the pair travel
into the subway which is where he's
bitten by a spider that gives him
incredible abilities miles constantly
running away from his responsibilities
and refusing to live up to his full
potential is what eventually leads to
his uncle getting killed and it's a
major turning point for the character
completely devastated miles returns home
and he's told to sit the next one out by
the other spider people though they
wanted him to be by their side they
didn't think that he was up to the
challenge and though they initially
trusted him over time they slowly lost
faith his father also returns to his
dorm and tries to have a heart to heart
with him but due to him being webbed up
he's unable to have a conversation
however what he does do is tell him that
whatever he chooses to do he will be
great at finally harnessing his powers
miles manages to break free from the
trappings he finds himself in and this
is symbolic on a number of levels not
only has he finally come to grips with
his abilities but he's also escaped the
perception that the other spiders had of
him they believed he had to stay behind
and even held him in place so that he
was stuck there him breaking three of
these shows that he's going beyond what
they wanted for him and he's now his own
man from here we cut into the phenomenal
what's up danger scene which is laced
with lots of important imagery that
shows how far he's grown as a character
what's up danger
i see this this spark
it's amazing
whatever you choose to do with it you'll
be great
our family doesn't run from things
you're the best of all of us
you know your way
when do i know i'm spiderman
[Music]
miles once more looks at the spider-man
suit but rather than his face being off
in the reflection it's now level with
the mask showing that he stepped into
the role and may also presents him with
two web shooters that she says fit
perfectly
they fit perfectly
both these moments mirror the ones from
earlier in the film in which his face
didn't line up and the costume didn't
fit him miles then climbs to the top of
the highest building he can find and
though he's unsure whether he will
actually be able to make the swing or
not he takes a literal leap of faith
into the beyond the glass rips off the
building and the air rushes past him
whilst the camera does something
inspired to show his ascension the angle
is flipped vertically so rather than
falling miles looks like he's now rising
into the air metaphorically this shows
that he's traveling upwards flying
beyond what we ever thought he could do
and i still get goosebumps as the song
fully kicks in as he swings through the
city we take focus on the brand new red
spider symbol over the black suit and
lets us know that this new guy is here
to stay going from running along the
street mileton starts to sprint on top
of buses before he journeys up to
dashing along the windows of skyscrapers
this thing culminates with them
journeying up to the rooftops showing a
gradual progression from the bottom to
the top the scene ends with miles
unmasking and this shot was used
throughout the trailers when promoting
the movie though we're well aware that
miles was under it now at the time of
its release this came as a big surprise
for years and years we'd only seen peter
parker on the big screen and thus miles
unmasking showed a change in direction
it also highlights one of the core
messages of the film which is that
anyone can be a hero throughout the
movie this was taken to be used purely
for spider-man but what miles represents
is that we all have the ability to be
heroic within ourselves we are very much
the heroes of our own stories and miles
is supposed to inspire us to believe
that anyone can be under the mask and
that if he can do it then we can too as
he leaps across the sky he comes across
the trustus bank which though a bit on
the nose shows that he's now fully began
to trust himself and the other spider
peeps they wanted him to live up to his
full potential but he didn't believe
that was possible and that they were out
of his league miles of sleep of faith is
very much symbolic of him moving
forwards towards something rather than a
way throughout the movie he's tried to
drop things that would cause him to take
on responsibility at any point the
character has never really stood his
ground and moved towards the danger and
because of this he's faced several
losses this included him messing up his
exams failing his first swing running
away from the fight that led to his
uncle's death and so on and so forth
however he's now running towards the
danger facing it head-on and accepting
all the responsibility that now rests on
his shoulders miles goes from a kid who
lacks the confidence to fully embrace
all that he can be but he takes on board
all the lessons that people try to
impart on him and finally jumps into the
void and becomes this earth's spider-man
it's an awesome coming-of-age scene that
works on its own even when viewed out of
the context of the film because of this
it very much feels like a music video
that's also a comic book which has come
to life the panels that appear out to
this and the dawning buildings that
litter the sky show the concrete jungle
that he's about to make his playground
this is one of the best scenes in a
comic book movie ever and you do its
subtext meaning and the build-up to it i
think that it's absolutely perfect this
is a scene that i go back to time and
time again and it sums up the message of
the movie whilst also introducing miles
to the general audience this is a
character that remained in the comics
for a long time but with the recent
video games and spider-verse movies it's
great to see him finally getting the
appreciation he deserves and i think
that this scene is where it all stems
from it's absolutely perfect and i hope
you enjoyed us discussing why we love it
so much now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on it so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the june box
set on the 28th of feb and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the perfect scene from
norway home which will be linked on
screen right now we talk about why the
one starring andrew garfield means so
much so definitely go check it out right
after this if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i've been poor
let's see in the next one take care
peace